my uh my entry point into this idea is
to coil right back so the fact that I
introduced this sort of sort of new
notation for you for talking about
functions
remember I said you're going to see
notation that looks like this right and
let's see on the left hand side doesn't
mean what we've trained you to teach me
for the last four years right so
normally when you see help the outside
racket with his old house run
you've normally interpret that as like X
times X right that's what we would
normally say but what we're describing
to you is actually quite different
s-save the cross for function and this
is the name of the function we could
call it anything we like and in fact as
you'll see in a minute um we're going to
quote quite different x who's going to
deal with a whole bunch of these all
together the most common name for a
function that you've seen in the past is
y right we said y equals and then we
supply a function of X what we mean by a
function of X is that X is the variable
you supply right this is the variable so
f is the name this is the function and
then this itself right this is the
function of X right you put X here you
get something else right so as you
evaluate this
and then you folks today okay I can add
F of five or elevated 1 or F of X plus
two you can put in any way since this
function now when I first introduced
this to you I said the reason why in but
once you've got is language you can call
do call you things with it and one of
the first examples is what we're looking
at this one which is part of even
functions you can't really describe what
these things are without this kind of
language so make a little something just
underneath this which is grant symmetry
it's crappy graph symmetry now I'd like
you to think for a moment with me and I
want you to help me think of examples
you know you've got underneath your belt
a whole bunch of different kinds of
graphs right you've been doing this for
years and many of the grants that you
are familiar with have various kinds of
symmetry to some of the complicated of
some of them are simple can someone give
you an example any example you buy of a
graph that you know which has some kind
of symmetry any technically I'm showing
to the one x equals y Jimmy if they lost
let's quickly draw and these don't have
to be large just enough to get the
picture let's do this thing okay x
equals y or y equals x a shield right
what does this look like well it's just
a straight line and here don't you
describe what the partner did the origin
and while ski told me about what
difference in this and say this
difference
the gradient is 1 in our tanks so let's
just spot that in there which by the way
if you remember the M equals 10 feet up
if M is 1 then tan theta would give me
this so Peter of course it is 105
there's one equal to X and X equal one
it's got a kind of symmetry how would
you describe it's immature
yes sir to measure Hill about whose
money fish that's a good way to describe
it let me repeat absolutely put it this
line is symmetrical about y equals minus
x right so if you just twist your head a
little bit and look at it sort of at an
angle you can see up this side is the
same as that side
that's good that's one way you could
describe it I'll come back to this guy
in a minute khun's actually a very
special case so I want to give you
another example of a symmetrical
function yes why can X well again can
you help me by drawing a little F of
this you have to have you again I will
pose the question to you what kind of
symmetry does this particular graph type
it's different to the first one how
would you describe it your work
sometimes anything you say again I can't
white with zero is only scratch where
means y equals zero why was there it
means vertically you're not hopping on
down you're just on the axis right
that's y equals zero there yeah and why
it was there is clearly important to
describe but it's modest appointed to
this symmetry of this ground right y
equals zero actually doesn't describe
anything about which way this graph is
the same that's by learn what symmetry
means agreement in measurements like two
minutes anyway so if the y equals zero
there's another lines very similar to
this that also gives you a symmetry
relationship where is it x equals zero
right that will give it to you at the in
fact let's draw that over the top okay
now just because I hadn't planted you
guys gave me a graph you have Michael's
ex-wife from x squared a natural
progression would be like oh that's cute
which also has symmetry and a different
kind again
all our folks let's draw this with a
nice little run of masculine huge our
life is an excuse we don't like was X
cubed looks like we haven't drawn a
third I will play down it's very similar
to one of the trigonometric graphs that
you know like with X cube in its basic
shape which chin graph which compared to
its similar than attend similar though
with one crucial difference there I know
what the primary difference between each
other bins
okay so 10x obviously it has its own it
happens open it's stuff between their
unlike like X cube which just goes on
forever but actually something important
happens at the origin please like this
wife was excuse you actually have to
draw a little horizontal spot there at
the origin and then it turns up loose
all right in the same way you go to your
left you go for that horizontal bit and
then you could this is distinct to y
equals 10x we're not going to drive it
how's it different at the origin what's
different okay this guy is just kind of
like comes up these sliders down just
pause for a minute have any launches
back off right can doesn't do that today
just blows straight through out of a
angle at a 45 degree angle
in fact which we'll explore in the next
topic so this is why please excuse I
think we can all agree it has symmetries
but it does not have the symmetry to
describe young think about it it doesn't
have the symmetry described here
I think per moment come to you to submit
that such a thing can look by the way I
know it looks like that white with next
country it looks like it but it's not
can you see why it's not if I drew in
this um y equals negative XY that Eric
suggested for that lighter day which is
okay right
do you see you could not reflect it over
and get the right shade you saw what
happen in fact see this light here it's
going to do this you see that it's not
what we want right it what actually
symmetrical
that went close but not quite so what is
the symmetry that this has okay so we
certainly applied this no one said the
word though because we kind of view it
as insurance surgery these two kind of
symmetry here are what we call
reflectional symmetry I think that's
mostly what people think of when they
say something is symmetrical right there
control butterfly just flip it over or a
mirror flip it over reflection this is
not reflectional symmetry this is got
two words you could call it along with
this you can call it rotational symmetry
Cheyenne suggested that if we take the
beam and then we turn it 180 degrees
clip being happening right take into the
same orientation and rotate it if you
rotated around 180 degrees you'll get
the exact same shape back but just like
these two right sorry just like these
two you have to pick a place right um
not just any light is good enough for
the reflectional symmetry there's a
particular line right we said line
symmetry okay in the same way there's a
particular place around which we rotate
this knavery the origin is one point
let's destroy them okay because there's
one point it will only called rotational
symmetry it also point symmetry now the
thing she says you guys picked out one
exit why first as a crap if it was why
is super address special because you
learn it enhance the reflection of
symmetry that Eric pointed out at the
beginning which it also has rotational
symmetry like you can take take that guy
you can spit around Madrid erase it
still works so he has multiple forms of
signature and platings a bit unusual
now the two I want to highlight are
actually should be through here wife is
x squared and y equals x cubed we call
these guys different kinds of surgery we
in fact for this one even symmetry or we
call it and because like an x squared
it's a puncture we say
even function and this guy over here we
call it odd symmetry or because y equals
x cubed a function we call that less you
an odd function any takers
why do you think we call even symmetry
even symmetry you understand when you
don't need to draw it just imagine it we
could keep going couldn't we we stopped
at X cubes but you could do X to the 4 5
6 7 etc okay if you did X to the 4 as
I'm going to be made even clearer on to
you excellent for looks very similar to
x squared it actually looks like x
squared except if it gained some weight
and it's like fat at the bottom okay
that's an X to the fourth but you go
check the decimals if you like it does
intersect at two crucial points can you
guess what they are
think about it at x equals 1 and 1
squared is the same as 1 to the 4 so
instead but then it goes higher why is
that why do you think you get this
deeper or the cow is higher right that
means the numbers grow faster anyway
that's a bit of an aside my point is it
has exactly the same symmetry that x
squared and you can bench upon $1 that X
to the 6 and X to the 60 anything with
an even power will have even symmetry